eine hyper fahrerlager für bank
ein alltag wie im kino verbrecher jagen
das böse eliminieren dass die
landläufige vorstellung eines polizisten
alltags wie viel hat das wirklich mit
der realität zu tun
wir wollen es herausfinden ob die von
der polizei basel landschaft nimmt uns
mit
er zeigt uns ungefiltert seinen alltag
[Musik]
vor der bank ist es ruhig das ist ein
[Applaus]
fehler
aber die user kann ist eine metro jeder
fall ist in der nacht nach dem alarm
seien aber zwischen nicht passiert bei
einem einsatz weiß ich nicht was er vor
ort genau an trifft er muss immer mit
dem schlimmsten rechnen auch wenn das
nur selten eintrifft auch jetzt eine
frau schlägt alarm
seit zwei tagen kein lebenszeichen von
ihrem nachbarn
normalerweise sind sie täglich in
kontakt sein briefkasten geleert die
storen unten
[Musik]
capri bekommt informationen von seinem
kollegen geschlossen
minute folgen wie vor marin
der hauptgang mit dem schlüsseldienst
oder
ungewohnt die situation dass mehr zu
machen war
was ist passiert
es kommt ja gut habt ihr darüber
langsam
nicht zuletzt wegen solcher momente ist
die chappuis polizist geworden
es ist grund halte ich das man bisher
unterstützen bürger dass sie ihre
geschichte an stimmen dass sie in den
salons was ihnen wichtig ist und das
mögliche problem das der fall gehört
läuft 55 mal pro tag rückt die polizei
das landschaft durchschnittlich aus
schnell umschalten ist gefragt von einem
fall zum nächsten der notruf einer
mutter ihr sohn wurde auf dem schulweg
von einem mann attackiert hat sich
versteckt und dann gewünscht ist eine
sache
hat sich denn da versteckt hatte
startplatz das duckstein und dann hätte
ohne aussage hatte die mit beiden fisch
zur box und der tash selber bisher
schwierig zu bewegen wie schaut sich den
tatort an
der junge soll ihm zeigen wo und wie
sich der mann versteckt hat nirgendwo
ein fall mit vielen fragezeichen
menschen ruhig das ist etwas regen
hausaufgabe die fälle aufnehmen und dann
der staatsanwaltschaft übergeben
2017 wurden in basel landschaft 37
prozent aller delikte aufgeklärt
zeit für eine verschnaufpause chappuis
und sein kollege nicola bären kreieren
im garten des polizeipostens ein moment
der ruhe im hektischen polizisten alltag
also wenn die hütte wird service läuft
es dann würde ich mit zweimal überlegt
es nochmals machen warum es so recht
belastendes also vor allem die
unregelmäßige arbeitszeiten früher mal
nach neue mittel denn mit der schaltung
das budget belastet das heißt vor ort la
casa reha marcus creed und grünen ist
dementsprechend zum teil verändert
und das content familie oppelt
personellen familie und kollegen
aber so ist zu brav ist spannend und
kolben und verbraucher nichts gemacht
eine überraschende aussage nicht der
psychologische teil zählt es sind die
arbeitszeiten die den zweifachen
familienvater belasten
heute hat schott oberschicht das heißt
von 6 uhr morgens bis mittags um halb
eins und dann die ganze nacht bis am
nächsten morgen um 6
noch ist es ruhig noch kein alarm
reduziert und eine aufgeweckte von
erster funk wartet aber hört sie also
noch 15 jahre ist das alt materie zu
schauen denn darunter bisher das alles
kommt mit
an diesem tag kommt nicht viel
außer einer verlorenen radkappe
in der nacht aber geht es schlag auf
schlag
ein einbruch in einem hotel
[Musik]
das wissen und er will und trucks marias
leider verloren
themen sind
genau
weißt du
ängste oder rechts
das gut
wenn das erste bauteil bis das objekt
umstellen
das hat eckpunkt durch sicher ins dunkel
und ostsee warten sie dass einige der
musiker nicht aus dem fenster und die
hektisch menschen wirklich unwohl ist
also immer noch die antwort sie
untermalen bereitschaft ein bisschen
parat gezückt hatte sie in seiner 15
jährigen dienstzeit schon oft abgedrückt
noch verstärkung ist eingetroffen
dann können wir unser ruhige rastatt
vielleicht das mit der realität wird
will das war monatelang großen fall
und nicht nur irgendwie nach anderthalb
stunden und kriege ich hoffe sie etwas
bevorteilt drei uhr morgens
sie rücken erneut aus eine betrunkene
beschimpft in einer bar gäste wirft
gläser und verletzt dabei eine man die
security stellt sie vor die tür
sie weigert sich zu gehen das wird als
helfer 15 minuten später ging es um sie
geschehen
sie hat kein ausweis verrät aber name
und wohnungen zu stand für einmal
taxifahrer empfindlich wenn es jetzt
also eine wichtige option besteht in ihm
erfahren und sich erledigt option b mit
den handschellen acv of the southern
district als ohne theater nach jetzt
einen anderen drei messer der andere
wichtige sache sehr kurz
unter dem punkt sonstiges ich bitte sie
biete jetzt die nun ganz einfach weil
man jetzt handschellen
[Musik]
sie verbringt die nacht in der
ausnüchterungszelle
neben erlebnisse wie dieses einem
längerfristig den glauben an das gute
bleiben solche beleidigungen hängen und
mich persönlich stört ein flüssiger
marco kutscher und wenn sie dann kann
ich glaube ich würde nicht so viel böse
worte bringen selbst wenn die welt ob es
geht im moment wirklich dankbarkeit
erlaubt vor der litt und das macht es
dann wieder gehört ich habe nie versucht
jedem fall gerecht zu werden
mal lässt der nähe zu malweise sich
abzugrenzen
auf dem weg zu einem schwer erziehbaren
17-jährigen es soll umplatziert werden
von einer gastfamilie in ein heim
logischer trocken und teils
gebäudeinnere bietet verstärkung auf
polizeistaat
meine handschrift sich hoch und macht
uns einfach davon
ich würde ja einfach fünf fehler zeit
vom 17 jährigen fehlt jede spur
okay das ist normal weil das simuliert
bei der deutlich gemacht und dann hat
der verbesserungen gezogen
der jugendliche wird zur fahndung
ausgeschrieben
diese alltag immer wieder überraschend
ja das geht einem schon ein blick in
andere lebensart oder in andere
problematiken selber zum glück und
wenigsten
das ist doch also ist eine interessante
die verschiedenen geschichten körpers
bearbeiten damit sie aber es geht einem
gewissen situationen schutz danken was
abgeholt und gesellschaft
beach abrückt aus nicht immer ist es wie
im krimi
aber jede kleine sache hat das potenzial
sich dazu zu entwickeln
[Musik]